[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
ROBERT TOWNSEND: All right.
So let's take a look
at where we are.
On the calendar, we're
at lecture 17 today.
As I said last time,
lectures 16, 17, 18 and 19
are all about
Walrasian equilibria
and their properties.
So we did the welfare theorems,
which we can review again
momentarily today
about existence
of all raising equilibria.
And while we're at it, how we
could interpret the Walrasian
equilibrium as the outcome
of the game using a Nash
equilibrium notion.
And then, we get to these two
juxtaposed lectures, 18 and 19.
Gorman aggregation
has to do with when
it looks as if there
were far fewer households
than there actually are, because
we're able to add them up.
That takes some pretty
strong assumptions
that we've already gone through
in terms of linear income
expansion paths.
So we'll review that.
And then, identification
is, if you go the other way
and assume almost nothing
other than rationality,
are you capable of
rejecting the model?
And then, the last
two lectures are
about failures of
the welfare theorems
and relatedly,
monetary economics.
We're moving right along.
In terms of what you
should be reading,
ideally, I don't
if you guys ever
do read these start articles.
But let me just point
out that you should be.
And in particular,
today, lecture 17 today--
so on the course
posting under Canvas,
there'll be the Kreps section
6.4 on existence and number
of equilibria.
Some of the diagrams from
today come from that chapter.
Although obviously, there's
more in there in the book
than there is in the lecture.
And also, this course material--
Asu's stuff from a
different MIT course.
She's got a really great
lecture on existence
of Nash equilibrium.
And I borrowed that quite a bit.
The entire lecture is
posted on our website,
but we will cover a big
chunk of it today in class.
So those are the two
starred readings.
And then, we get to
a bit of a review.
So this is a bit challenging,
but I'll ask it anyway.
It really has to do with stating
the first welfare theorem,
and then outlining for us the
steps necessary to prove it.
So Daniel, you want to take a
crack at that by any chance?
You remember the steps for
proving the first welfare
theorem?
AUDIENCE: If I recall correctly,
the first welfare theorem
was that under the assumption
of everybody being rational
and [INAUDIBLE].
I think that might have been it.
There is a lambda-weighted--
then, the economy will
create a lambda-weighted--
it will maximize the
lambda-weighted sum
of the utilities of the people.
And the proof-- yeah, I
don't think I remember
the steps of the proof.
AUDIENCE: Can I
take a shot at it?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Sure.
AUDIENCE: If I
remember correctly,
the proof goes something
like, for each person,
because of the
budget constraint,
any outcome that would
be strictly preferred
by that person would
require a larger budget.
And so in order for
something to be or not to--
for the allocation,
whatever everyone ends up
getting not to be
free to optimal,
it would require
everyone getting--
it would require at least--
it would require all the
budgets to either be the same
or increased.
But you can't-- and if you
also factor in the price,
the profit maximization part,
you can do the same thing
on the production side.
And you basically end up getting
an impossible situation, where
you have to have
more stuff being
consumed than being produced
because of market [INAUDIBLE]..
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yep,
that's very good.
That was a very,
very good outline.
So the first welfare theorem
says that any Walrasian
equilibrium is optimal.
And the proof is
by contradiction.
Suppose it's not optimal.
Then, there's
something that's weakly
preferred by some households and
strictly preferred by others.
And then, as was just said, the
strictly preferred by others
means it could not have been
available, because it otherwise
would have been purchased
in Walrasian equilibria.
And then, we had a little lemma
that was quite subtle even
for those guys who weekly prefer
the alternative allocation,
they too would be
spending weekly more.
And so we get the
total expenditure
summing up over
all the households
that would be necessary
at the competitive prices
to achieve the alternative
allocation to be strictly
greater than what is being spent
in the competitive allocation.
Then, we add that to
profit maximization.
And we get a relationship, a
strict inequality relationship,
which at the end of the day
said that the allocation
in the alternative--
allocation that's supposed
to be Pareto dominating
is not resource-feasible.
But the definition
of Pareto optimality
is that there is a dominating--
if something's not optimal,
it can be dominated by
something that is feasible.
So the feasibility part
will be contradicted,
and that was the proof.
OK, so you'll see
this theorem again
when we get to that last
lecture on monetary economics.
It's going to turn out that
under certain conditions
like having overlapping
generations of people
so that no person lives forever,
but time goes on forever,
that that's enough to
make the first welfare
theorem fail, surprisingly, when
we get into monetary economics.
And the proof then
begs the issue
of where this proof
is breaking down.
And it's going to turn
out that the valuation
of the alternative bundle at the
competitive equilibrium prices
costs an infinite amount.
So we implicitly
assume everything
is finite in this finite
dimension of Euclidean space.
Anyway, just to anticipate.
Second thing I want to
ask about is similar.
Outline the steps of the proof
of the second welfare theorem
that we did in class last time.
So I don't expect a
lot of detail on this,
but let's see who would like to.
Yuen, can you
volunteer for that?
AUDIENCE: Sure, yeah.
So the second welfare
theorem states
that any Pareto
optimal allocation
can be achieved by
some price equilibrium,
assuming that you can shift
endowment point under exchange.
And so in the Lagrangian
maximization problem,
basically, you're finding
the actual endowment
that will give you the
correct price equilibrium
corresponding to the desired
Pareto optimal allocation.
And you can do
that just by first
solving the Pareto problem to
get the first order conditions
reallocations.
And then, you can solve the
Walrasian equilibrium problem--
so the consumer and the firm
side problem separately.
And then, you just match the
first order of conditions.
So the appropriate parameters,
like the shadow prices,
need to equal the prices
in the price equilibrium--
stuff like that.
And you can show that all these
things exist in our system.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Perfect, yep.
The key is the
Lagrangian method,
which under convexity in sets
and concavity in functions
makes the first order conditions
necessary and sufficient.
So to find a solution,
all you need to do
is find variables and
shadow prices that satisfy
those first order conditions.
We have the obvious candidate,
because we start with a Pareto
optimal allocation.
So we just compare what we need
for the Walrasian allocation
to what we already have
from the Pareto problem--
allocation, and choose
prices, and Lagrange
multipliers, and
so on accordingly.
So your answer was perfect.
Thank you very much.
All right.
So that's so many
review questions,
because we really focused pretty
narrowly on those two theorems
in class.
So all right.
So then, the lecture
today is existence.
Sounds ominous.
[CHUCKLES] What does
it mean to not exist?
Well, as per the
welfare theorems,
I said with the first
welfare theorem,
if a competitive
equilibrium exists
and it's optimal, how do we know
it exists in the first place?
That's one way to put it.
Anyway, it's possible
that many things we do
are vacuous, because
we assume a concept
and assume an allocation
that satisfies the concept.
But we'd better
go back and check.
Along the way, there's
more interesting
stuff happening in
this lecture, which
has to do with reviewing the
definition of a Walrasian
equilibria and then seeing
how sufficient assumptions
for existence, but
also in principle,
how you might want
to compute it,
which brings us to modern day
platforms and online markets.
So it's not just abstract.
It's actually something
computer scientists
and fintechs worry
about quite a bit.
And relatedly, we'll compare
the Walrasian equilibria
to the Nash equilibria,
which is a different concept
of an equilibrium.
But it takes the same
sufficient conditions.
And again, that's a very,
very useful tool to master.
But we want to go beyond that.
We want to use it.
So I'm going to show you
some pictures of what's
going on in the New York
financial markets and date,
at least verbally, trade fails,
and when those markets get
messed up, as in the
Coronavirus in March.
And then, we'll think
about, are there
ways to clean up the markets
and avoid the failures that
have to do with market design.
So that's the agenda for today.
Mostly, it's conceptual
and notational.
And I have
deliberately taken out
a lot of the notation
necessary to look
at the actual mapping,
because it gets quite tedious,
actually.
And it's not really
the main point.
OK, so here's the math tools.
What do we mean by a
fixed point of a function?
We're going to want to
solve nonlinear equations.
We want to know whether or
not there is a solution.
Those could be excess demand
equations in the Walrasian
case, or reaction
functions in the Nash case.
We'll get there momentarily.
So a function, f, maps some
domain, A, back into itself.
And we're looking for
a particular value
of x star in the domain such
that when you stick it in,
you get it back out.
And what I mean by that
is, at x star, f of x star
is x star again.
The more formal statement--
Brower's Fix Point Theorem--
is at the bottom of this slide.
Let A be a subset of a finite
dimensional L dimensional
Euclidean space.
And that quote "domain"
being non empty, convex,
and compact," and f maps
that domain back into itself,
A to A, f is continuous,
that's enough conditions
on f and on this set
A such that there
is a special point,
x star, in A,
and when you stick it
into the function f,
you get x star right back again.
So what's going
on is pretty well
captured by this
classic picture.
The set A is just
the integral 0 to 1.
And that's the domain.
And the range is the
same, A to A, 0 to 1.
And this function f
is being drawn here
as a continuous function.
And the challenge would be,
how could you possibly draw
this function, which
has to be continuous,
in a way that it doesn't
cross the green diagonal?
This one clearly does.
So where it crosses, by
definition of the 45 degree
line we found, x star, we
get back what we put in.
So, oh, no.
I don't want to go down there.
How about we hug
the axis up here?
But even then, where
f of x is 1 for all x,
it would still be a fixed
point at the end point.
So anyway, that's the intuition.
It's pretty clearly sufficient
to have the fixed point.
And when you don't--
I'll show you a picture--
it's because it'll jump over.
It will not be
defined exactly where
it would need to be defined
to cross the 45 degree line.
This is a generalization
of Brower's theorem.
It's Kakutani's
Fixed Point Theorem.
A-- still the same,
a non empty subset
of a finite dimensional
Euclidean space.
f, however, doesn't have unique
single values in the range.
It could be a whole
set of values of f.
It's called a correspondence.
So we pick x in the domain.
There's a plausible
entire set of values--
f of x, which is a
subset of A. So then,
we just look at the
conditions on A,
which are already given to
us to be non empty, compact,
and convex, exactly as in
Brower, f of x is non empty.
Well, that's been
implicitly assumed
that it has a value for every x.
And here's some more--
convex-valued and closed.
So although it wasn't
about this, the question
he asked at the very
beginning-- so it's like this.
So f is convex-valued
means take any two
points in f of x, the convex
combination is also in f of x.
And closed simply means that if
you have a sequence of points,
xn and yn converging to x and y,
with every point along the way
in the sequence
satisfying yn, an element
of f of xn, then the limit
y is an element of f of x.
So again, it doesn't jump.
And then, Kakutani
tells us that these
are sufficient assumptions
for us to have a fixed point.
I wish this had been
written with a star here.
If x star is an
element of A, then x
star is an element of
f of x star, not equal.
Because we have a
correspondence, just
an element of.
So here is the jumpy picture
that I promised you--
the two exceptions.
F has to be convex-valued and
continuous, in some sense,
or have a closed graph.
Here, it's not convex-valued
at this particular point
in the domain.
It is not true that
any linear combination
of points in the range
are also in the range.
And in particular, there's
nothing in the middle here.
So it jumps over
that 45 degree line.
Likewise here, there's
a sequence of points--
actually, unique points.
Correspondence allows
single value functions.
But when you get
here, the limit point
is no longer consistent with
f of x being a point of x.
And the function drops down.
x is here. f of x is here.
That's fine.
That jump is fine.
But the problem is, this
can be achieved by a limit.
And the point in the
limit is not in the pair.
That's that little
Cheerio with a hole.
That's not an
argument of f of x.
So anyway, this is what can
go wrong to motivate the quote
"sufficient assumptions."
Now, we get to the
first application--
existence of Walrasian prices.
We want sufficient conditions.
Consider a pure
exchange economy.
Get rid of production.
Have a strictly positive
aggregate endowment.
Assume that preferences are
rational, locally nonsatiated,
and continuous.
In fact, preferences
can be represented
by utility functions.
The consumption set
is, say, all of the L
dimensional non-negative space.
So we define three things here.
First of all, we're defining
the maximizing demand.
So we maximize utility
function subject to consumption
being in the consumption set,
subject to not spending more
than the valuation of the
endowment at this price, p.
That's the definition
of demand for all prices
p given parametrically.
Z will call excess demand--
namely, not total demand, but
the difference between demand
and the endowment.
This is typically positive
if they're buying stuff.
It could be negative if
they're selling stuff.
And yeah, we just
call it excess demand.
And then, we take the sum
of the excess demands,
summing over all the households.
This is I, capital I. So this
is the aggregate excess demand
function.
Now, if we can find a price,
p, such that this z of p is 0,
then we're done.
Why?
Because we found
the p such that when
we march across the
different households,
we have excess demand being
positive for some people.
But since it has to sum
to 0, that excess demand
has to be negative.
So whatever gets supplied by
households, some households,
gets demanded by
other households.
By the way, all of this is
written in vector notation,
although it's not obvious.
You have to be reminded of that.
We want to be able to clear each
and every one of the L markets
with this price vector p.
OK, so here's a
picture where it works,
and a picture where it doesn't.
The aggregate
endowment is over here.
And we'll look, despite
what I just said, at good 1.
Take the price of good 1.
Here's the demand
for it, total demand.
This is total supply.
Excess demand hits 0 right here.
We're done.
We found a price--
this price, where
excess demand is 0,
because supply is
equal to demand.
But if it were to happen that
somehow those demand curves
jump, then for some prices,
excess demand is positive
and for others, it's negative.
And we would not find
0 of that function.
So when can this happen?
I didn't draw the picture here,
but if you take an Edgeworth
box diagram, you can
imagine that households
might jump from wanting all of
good x to wanting all of good y
at a certain price.
And maybe if you set it up
even with more restrictions,
they're not very happy with
stuff in the middle, either--
for example, with not
concave indifference curves,
but convex indifference curves.
The linear stuff won't
work, because they'll
be happy in the middle.
But when it's a
concave function,
or convex indifference curves,
or concave upper contour sets,
then they will only
want to go to extremes.
And that's going
to create a hole.
So I think it's not written out.
But you're going to see
it indirectly in a minute.
We need sufficient convexity
of consumption sets,
and concavity of
utility functions,
and if we had production,
some convexity
assumptions there in order
to get the conditions to be
able to use the fixed point.
Remember, the
fixed point assumes
that functions are
continuous and the domain
of the underlying
mapping is closed,
and convex, and nonempty.
Now, I could have put
many more slides in here.
In earlier years, I
used to have them.
It's surprisingly tedious.
This was the work done by
Arrow, and Debreu, and McKenzie
in the '50s and the '60s.
And the mapping is
not as straightforward
as you might hope.
It's certainly nothing
like these pictures.
But I think the intuition
is fine for today.
Now, much more relevant
since, we just did it,
would be Negishi's mapping.
Instead of looking for
prices that clear markets,
we're going to look for
Pareto weights using
the first and second
welfare theorem.
Again, exactly what
we did last time.
The first welfare
theorem tells us
that the competitive equilibrium
will be Pareto optimal.
And we're going to be
having enough assumptions so
that that theorem
is true-- local non
satiation and rationality.
So we know, if it's optimal,
there exists Pareto weights
lambda such that when we
solve the lambda weighted max
problem, we will get that
particular Pareto optimal
allocation.
Not any lambda--
particular lambdas
that generate that particular
Pareto optimal allocation
corresponding to the
Walrasian equilibrium.
So that's Negishi's method.
Instead of trying to find
prices that clear markets,
it's going to try to
find Pareto weights--
in particular,
Pareto weights such
that we're searching
as we vary the Pareto
weights over the space of Pareto
optimal allocations in such
a way that the fixed
point of a mapping
will be the particular
Pareto weights that generate
the Walrasian allocation.
And in particular, the valuation
of the expenditures associated
with the competitive
equilibrium is exactly
the valuation of wealth under
the private ownership economy.
So those are the words
and the notations coming.
It's three or four slides away.
OK, so what does Negishi do in--
he actually adds up over firms.
So we act like there's
just one single firm.
That's perfectly fine to do.
It just makes the
notation easier.
And these assumptions
are pretty much what
we did last time when
we did the Lagrangian
and the second welfare theorem.
The consumption sets
are closed and convex.
Let's say they contain 0.
That's a little
bit more special.
Utility functions are
continuous concave functions
with local non satiation.
We define an aggregate
consumption set,
the aggregate social endowment,
the aggregated production
of the representative
firm, which is also convex
and has a concave
transformation,
possibility of an action
in the production set,
and feasibility--
in particular, the existence
of an interior point,
and that the feasible set
of allocations is compact.
This compactness
may seem strange.
And I can come back
to that if you want.
Certainly, if you had an
Edgeworth box economy,
the set of aggregate
resources is fixed and finite.
Production creates the
possibility of creating more,
but you have a finite
number of inputs, and so on.
So in the end, you end
up with a compact set.
All right.
So Negishi's theorem, 1960--
suppose we have a
private ownership
economy with this
string of elements
that you're now very familiar
with that satisfy A.1
through A.4, all the convexity,
and concavity, and continuity,
and so on.
Then, voila.
There exists a
Walrasian equilibrium.
x star, y star, p star.
Let's assume utility
functions are differentiable.
F is differentiable.
We did that anyway with
the second welfare theorem.
So the key here is that
Pareto optimal allocations
are indexed by lambda.
This simple-looking problem,
which is, pick a lambda vector,
maximize lambda-weighted
sums of utilities
by choices of consumption
and production
that are in consumption
sets, production sets,
and satisfy the
resource constraint
for each of the L goods.
You saw a slide
like this last time
with the second welfare theorem.
Here, we're going
to explicitly index
the solution of a given
lambda as x and y lambda.
So for a given lambda, a
particular target Pareto
optimal allocation
is the solution
to this Pareto problem.
Now again, said this earlier.
We know there is a lambda, of
course, that generates a Pareto
optimal allocation that
corresponds to the Walrasian
equilibrium.
And more generally, from
the second welfare theorem,
any Pareto optimal
allocation hence
has a particular
lambda such that it
can be achieved as a competitive
equilibrium with transfers.
So let's just search in
the space of Pareto optimal
allocations till we
find the right one,
find the Walrasian one.
And in particular,
the prices are
going to happen along the way.
They are the Lagrange
multipliers associated
with the resource constraints.
This is exactly, in fact, the
same notation from last time,
except that this gamma,
which is the price vector,
is indexed by lambda when
we matched up, remember,
the consumer problem
with the first order
conditions in the
Walrasian equilibrium
with the first order conditions
of the Pareto problem.
And we also will get,
from the Pareto problem,
the consumer's allocation,
the firm's allocation,
these prices, again,
as I just mentioned,
and the wealth allocation.
And the wealth for a given
lambda for a given Pareto
optimal allocation
is just the valuation
at these Lagrange
multiplier prices
of the target Pareto
optimal x allocation.
This is a given.
I here is a household I.
We're summing over all the L
goods, finite number of them.
And so again, add lambda x hat.
Add lambda of L--
is the demand for the Lth good.
This is the price
of the Lth good.
We sum over all of the L goods.
We get total expenditures.
And we assign that wealth level.
You may remember that slide.
I said, why do we need this?
And I kept reminding you of
the global algorithm, which
is, we have to make sure the
assignments of wealth that
correspond with supporting
prices of the Pareto problem
sum up to the total
social endowment.
So you saw this before.
What are we looking for?
We're looking for an
assignment of wealth such
that the wealth is equal
to the valuation of wealth
in the private
ownership economy.
So this is just the
endowment of household I
plus household I's claim
on the shares of the firm.
You used to have theta
Ij summation over j,
but because for
simplicity we assumed
1 representative
aggregated firm,
we only need theta
I, not theta Ij.
It's I's claim on the profits
of the firm, the single firm.
Anyway, that's
private ownership.
So we're looking
for lambdas somehow.
And again, I didn't go much
further with the mapping.
We're going to iterate
on lambdas in such a way
that eventually, we define
the mapping in such a way
that the lambda that
we want will be a fixed
point of the mapping
and will satisfy
the valuation of expenditures
at that particular Pareto
optimum is exactly the
valuation of wealth
in the private
ownership economy.
Again, the mapping
is a bit more tedious
than you might hope for.
On the other hand, you can see
clearly from the second welfare
theorem how we were using
convexity, and continuity,
and so on.
So perhaps it's
not too surprising,
at the end of the
day, that we end up
with sufficient assumptions to--
oh, here it is.
Here I am talking away.
Sufficient assumptions to get
this particular lambda star
as the fixed point we want.
I said this in words,
and I should have
had this slide on the board.
Valuation of expenditures
equals the valuation
of wealth in the private
ownership economy.
So there's really
two ways to search
for a competitive equilibrium.
We can search in price space, or
we can search in lambda space.
It's curious that in both
cases, we need a simplex.
To remind you, a
simplex is the space
where each of the elements
is non-negative greater than
or equal to 0, and the sum
of the elements adds up to 1.
So prices add up
to 1, because we
have a degree of freedom for
the normalization of prices,
because of homogeneity
of degrees 0,
and homogeneity of
degree 1, I guess.
And also in the lambda weights,
the lambdas are normalized.
They're non-negative.
And they sum up to 1.
So that's another simplex.
But on the other
hand, the dimensions
may be easier in
the lambda space.
Maybe there are more goods than
there are types of households.
We have inputs and
outputs of all kinds.
There may be, at least
for economic modeling--
we can think about a finite
number of types of households.
Maybe when you think about
wealth, we have rich and poor.
We have medians.
We have quartiles.
When we thought about
international trade,
we had households differing
by their endowments.
Some are laborers.
Some own the capital, and so on.
So typically, the number
of lambdas corresponding
to the number of
types of households
is less than the number
of prices we need.
And it's just easier,
therefore, to search and compute
in the lambda space.
Anyway, I thought you
might appreciate this,
because we just got done with
the second welfare theorem.
And this existence
proof uses that.
Now, lest we think
it's just elegant,
I turn to what's going
on in computer science--
namely, how to find the
Walrasian equilibrium.
So Echenique and
Wierman at Caltech,
actually, have some
really cool stuff.
It can actually be
pretty hard to find
the competitive equilibrium.
We draw simple pictures, right?
But you have lots of households.
And in particular, households
could be posting information
on websites.
And we want to run some
auction or something.
And hopefully, there
are enough households
that we're trying to get to
the Walrasian allocation.
It's not easy to
solve these things.
In fact, in general, it looks
like a very hard problem.
And look, the examples of how
to find it look relatively easy.
So there's this big
gap in the literature.
Anyway, these guys
discovered Negishi.
Everybody goes back to 1960.
And they have an
algorithm that works
to find the competitive
equilibria using
Negishi's algorithm
that I just showed you.
And this one is related.
Computing Walrasian
equilibria fast.
[CHUCKLES] So again,
there's stuff here.
Although it's cool in the
sense of writing a code
that iterates.
And you want to know
the time that it
takes to find the solution.
And hopefully, that's not
going up exponentially
with the number of households,
or the number of goods,
or something.
So they want it to work fast.
So they don't want to evaluate
derivatives all the time.
So they figured out
this algorithm that
makes a call to the oracle.
And the oracle, when consulted,
will tell them the derivative
of the excess demand curve.
And so they've got this down.
They only have to consult the
oracle relatively few times.
And it's polynomial.
And so they can-- this
algorithm works pretty quickly.
This language of
consulting oracles
is used in computer
science any time
you want to go to an
external data source.
And could be rainfall, or
stock prices, or whatever.
And then, bring
that into the code--
like The Matrix oracle.
OK, let's go to another
concept of equilibrium,
Nash equilibria, and define
a strategic form game.
Let me back up a second.
The Walrasian
equilibrium is fine--
say, prices such
that when everyone
takes those prices as
given and maximizes,
then we look at the
resource constraint,
we find the prices such
that excess demands are 0.
But that does beg the issue
of where the heck the prices
are coming from.
Even if we have algorithms
for finding them,
that's a step along the way.
The strategic form
games are ways
to be very explicit about
the strategies and outcomes
that traders are using.
And again, I'll link this
up to the Walrasian price
momentarily.
OK, so here are
some definitions.
A strategic form game
has a finite number
of players, capital I,
script I. There there's
a set of possible actions
for each player, S sub
I. A particular action,
little si, is in big SI.
So that's a particular action
in a set of all possible actions
that define the game.
And the payoff functions--
look like utility functions--
map the actions
into real numbers.
But this vector, capital
S here, is actually
the actions of all the players,
unlike, say, in a Walrasian
equilibrium, where prices are
given and you choose demands.
Here, we need to map
explicitly the actions of each
and every player in order
to determine the outcome,
and hence determine the
utility of each player.
Here's some convenient notation.
S of minus I means
everybody but I.
So it's the particular
actions of all players j
excluding player I.
Likewise, capital S sub I is
the set of all possible actions
over all players other
than I. And finally,
this notation S
sub I S sub minus I
is the strategy profile.
It's particularly
relevant for player I,
because it has his or her
own action in there, S sub I,
but also as a summary,
the actions of all
the other players, S 0 I.
OK, so these are the definitions
of a strategic form game--
actions, utilities, and so on.
So a strategy is how
to play the game, how
to choose particular actions.
It's as if you were writing
code to tell yourself
what to do as a function of
what everyone else is doing.
So this can be easy or hard.
Nowadays, you could program
computers to play chess.
But that's thought to be
a pretty hard problem.
But this is the way we think
about agents choosing what
to do in a strategic form game.
So instead of jumping to a
notion of a Nash equilibrium
right away, let's think
about probability measures
over pure strategies.
But let me just say
from the beginning,
why are we doing this?
If you thought there's a finite
discrete number of actions
for two players, then player
one could do one thing,
and conditioned on that, player
to would choose his thing.
And again, conditioned on
what player two is doing,
player one wants to change his
mind and do something else.
So in principle, it
could jump all around
and never find a set
of consistent actions.
But if instead we think
about each player choosing
his or her action at random,
then we're back to the simplex.
Because the set of
probability numbers
are going to be non-negative
and add up to 1.
So you can see where
we're going, right?
We're going to map
this into Kakutani.
So that's why,
right away, we start
talking about probability
measures over pure strategies.
So for example, if
you had two actions,
you could think about
this probability measure
as assigning a
probability of doing
one thing or the other
thing, or the probability
over any finite
number of things.
And we call these probability
measures mixed strategies,
sigma being the mixed
strategy of player
I in the set of all
probability measures
that put mass over actions.
So sigma sub I for player
I, sigma without the I
is a set of mixed
strategies over everybody,
over all the players.
And it is being assumed
here that there's
no coordination, that they're
randomizing independently.
Sigma minus I is
the mixed strategies
of every player other than I.
And you can think about the
utility function of player I
as a function of the vector of
sigma that everyone is playing.
Why?
Because sigma includes not just
I, but all the other players.
It's a random way
of choosing actions.
And a function of a given set
of configuration of actions
will generate a
payoff, and hence
generate the utility
of each agent I.
So this is just
expected utility.
This is just a Von Neumann
Morgenstern expected utility
explicitly taking into
account the random way
that allocations are achieved.
And I've been a bit vague
about the strategy space, S.
Sometimes, I said it was
finite, like two actions.
This bottom line
specification here
is like, there could be a
continuum of possible actions.
So we integrated rather
than summing things up.
OK, so let's finally
define a Nash equilibrium.
Mixed strategy Nash equilibrium
is a strategy profile star
for each and every
player such that player
I here takes as given
the mixed strategy,
the star mixed strategy
of all the other players,
and hopefully will find
the sigma I star for him
or herself is, in fact,
not worse in utility terms
than doing any other
mixed strategy.
So Nash is always, take as given
what everyone else is doing.
And then, you're fully
free to optimize.
And you can see
where this is going.
It's a bit more complicated.
We're going to
look for some kind
of fixed point in
these mixed strategies
so that when we put sigma star
in, we get sigma star back out.
One curious thing here,
not that it matters,
but it's interesting to think
about the out of equilibrium
problem of a given agent.
The agent takes as
given the sigma I
star of all the other
players less himself,
and then would in
principle, be looking
for a mixed strategy that might
do better than sigma I star.
But the mixed strategy
would be putting mass
on potential non-trivial
number of actions.
But if one action in
the mixed strategy
provides higher utility
than the other, then player
I would always
choose that action.
Why randomize over other things
that give you less utility?
So in fact, to try to guard
against alternatives that
do better, you only need to
evaluate over pure strategies,
not mixed strategies.
But anyway, the
definition is all on Nash
that sigma I star here is
going to weakly dominate
any other pure strategy SI
given that the other players are
doing sigma star minus I.
So that's the definition
and a proposition.
Now finally, we
get the dividend.
Every finite game has a mixed
strategy Nash equilibrium.
It's huge, hugely important.
And again, you could
write down a game.
But how do we know that it
even has Nash equilibrium?
Now we know that if it's a game
with a finite number of actions
for every player, it does
have a Nash equilibrium.
It may not be a pure
strategy equilibrium.
It may involve randomization.
But it exists.
And to come to the
fixed point part of it,
we're looking for this
profile sigma star
such that for every player
I, sigma I star weakly
dominates any other
strategy sigma I,
including pure
strategies, taking as
given what the other
players are doing.
In other words, if you start
with a sigma star, player
I would be reacting to what
the other players are doing
and choose the best
response given what
the other players are doing.
So indeed, this capital B
is the best response set.
There may be more than one
utility maximizing response.
If so, pick one.
It should be utility
maximizing per player I
given the configuration of
what everyone else is doing.
So now, we can talk about the
best response for player I,
taking as given what
other players are doing.
It's a bit tricky notation
here, because sigma I star
is what we want to find.
And this is the best
response given the strategies
of the others minus I.
And to be consistent
with the notation,
this B has a minus I on it.
But that does not mean that
these are the responses
of the other players j.
It is just a way of denoting
the best response for player
I conditioned on what all
the other guys are doing.
So minus I and
minus I both being
consistent with each other.
It's a bit weird in
terms of notation.
But so this B of
minus I-- minus I
means the best
response for player I.
We do that for all players
I and define it here.
This is BI.
Should have been a minus I.
I'll have to email Ashley.
Anyway, so we have
B of sigma to be
the configuration of
best responses for all
of the players.
And so we're looking
for a Nash equilibrium
to be a fixed point
of this mapping.
In particular, we
can find a sigma such
that given that sigma
for each player,
now knows what the other guys
are doing in the mixed strategy
sense, comes up with his or her
own best mixed strategy as part
of a best response.
Each player is doing
that and ends up
doing what they all took as
given to begin with-- namely,
sigma star.
So we just need this B thing
to have good properties.
And in particular,
this B thing turns out
to satisfy the conditions
of Kakutani's theorem.
It's operating over compact,
convex, nonempty sets.
Itself being nonempty, has a
convex value correspondence
and has a closed graph.
So then, we invoke
Kakutani and we're done.
So the second or third
illustration, now,
of Kakutani's
theorem, in this case,
to establish the existence
of a mixed strategy
Nash equilibrium
in a finite game--
are there questions?
All right.
So let's apply this artillery to
US markets and talk about trade
fails.
So a trade fail is where
a buyer of a treasury
agrees to hand over
liquidity-- money,
excess reserves-- to the
seller, who has a treasury.
And likewise, the
other guy, the seller,
is happy to supply the treasury
in return for the liquidity.
So buyer and seller meet.
They meet in over
the counter market.
It's not a centralized
Walrasian market.
And then, they're supposed to
show up and settle the trade.
Well, technically, the
seller of the treasury
may not yet own the
treasury, but is
planning to get a hold of
it in one way or the other
so as to be able to pass
the treasury from him
or herself to the buyer.
And likewise, the
buyer may or may not
have liquidity at the
time they strike the deal,
but is planning, hopefully,
to get a hold of the liquidity
in order to be able to buy to
pay for what they've already
agreed to do.
But it doesn't always
work out that way.
And there are settlement
fails in the system.
This happened, for example,
with a computer outage.
How can you settle trades
when it's all electronic
and there's nothing
on the screen?
9/11 was another problem where
there are a lot of disruptions.
Now, they all have backup
systems in New Jersey
and at Sanford, but
not at the time.
So as I said, the seller
may not have the securities.
One possibility is
that he was planning
to get them from someone
else, but that someone
else who was selling
the securities to him
for him to sell it to the
third party himself is failing.
So we get what we
call this daisy chain,
a cascade of failures.
So you really getting into
the weeds in terms of-- it's
not Walrasian.
It's not simple Nash.
It's a much more complicated
institutional arrangement.
But we're going to try to
use the Nash equilibrium.
Now, here's a picture
of the trade fails.
Although this was
between 1990 and 2014,
this paper from the New York Fed
is intended to be illustrative
of this surge of fails that
happened in the great financial
crisis of 2007, '07, '08.
So OK.
It's a spike.
So what?
We'll go over here,
say, higher than 9,000.
9,000 what?
9,000 billion.
We're talking trillions here.
This is unbelievable.
OK?
It doesn't get bigger than this.
In fact, the treasury market
is the world's highest value
market in the whole world.
And now, we have a
substantial fraction
of trades that have been
agreed to as failing.
I wasn't able to
update this slide,
but I did see a paper just two
days ago, which is basically,
this year--
starting, say, January,
February, March--
in March, the virus hit.
And trade fails
just skyrocketed.
So the Fed had convinced itself
that having enough reserves
on its books would
provide ample liquidity
to the system sufficient
so that we would never
see trade sales again.
They got it wrong.
I'm not sure how much
background you have.
But the Fed is
buying securities.
They're buying mortgage
backed securities
that other people wouldn't hold.
And for buying them, they
credit buyers, broker dealers,
and banks with accounts
at the Federal Reserve.
So those things are
called reserves.
They're well over
excess reserves.
That's where banks
keep excess value.
And they pay for stuff
with those reserves.
Banks don't borrow
from one another
very often anymore because
of all the excess reserves,
and so on.
But in March, it all fell apart.
And the Fed had to inject
even more liquidity.
So we're not quite ready
for monetary economics yet,
but we are ready to
talk about how to model
this market for securities.
So let's think
about it as a game,
a strategic game
played among traders.
So there's going to
be various goods,
like liquidity, treasuries.
We're back to our
usual notation here.
There are j goods, j equal
1 through not L, but k.
And there's going to
be a trading post--
a market, so to speak--
for each of the goods.
And they're going to buy
by paying unit of account
to get the good,
or sell the good,
and return get unit of
account into their accounts.
So agent I, trader
I, plays a strategy,
which has four objects.
Basically, can buy
or sell, but even
more than that, you
could buy and specify
a price pi for good j.
You're willing to
buy if the price is
less than or equal to that
price that you specified.
These are consumers, right?
So lower prices
are a good thing.
If you're willing to
buy at pi j for good j,
then you're willing to buy
if the price were less.
But you limit your exposure.
Regardless of whether
it's pi or less,
you're only going
to agree to buy
at most qij units of the goods.
So these are called
limit prices.
Then, that's the way the New
York Stock Exchange works,
et cetera.
Not all of the exchanges
work like this.
The tildes here denote
limit prices for sellers.
So a seller of good j will say,
well, I need a minimum price,
p tilde ij.
I'm willing to
sell at that price.
I'm willing to sell if
the price is higher,
but I'm not going to
sell an infinite amount.
I'm going to limit my
sales to q tilde ij.
So in this game,
all the traders are
submitting these limit orders.
And they effectively could
be on one side or the other,
or be willing to do both
depending on the prices
that they need.
So a strategy, S,
consists of the set
of possible actions, all these
configurations of vectors
for each of the
capital N players.
And then, we need to
denote the outcome.
The outcome function
is this function g--
we'll put it over here--
that if everyone is S, being S1,
S2, Sn for each of the players,
this vector S of
actions limit orders
submitted by all of
the end players maps
into a particular
outcome for player
I, trader I, which is
x, the excess demand
or supply, and beta.
And beta is a new object here.
It's going to be the net
credit that agent I receives
when strategy profile S
played by all the agents.
Beta is going to be the
total unit of account
an agent spends.
And if positive, if
positive, beta means
you spend less than what
you get as a seller.
You're a seller, you're getting
revenues in unit of account
from selling.
How much depends on what
everyone else put in.
If you're buying, then
you owe unit of account.
How much depends on what
everyone else is doing.
Beta could reflect the fact
that they sold more in value
in unit of account
than they demanded.
That would be a
good thing sort of.
They're just underspending.
The opposite is
a disaster, where
they've committed to spend unit
of account they don't have.
That's when beta goes negative.
That's a fail.
That's going to be a trade fail.
They can't come up
with the liquidity.
Or well, we want to prevent
that from happening.
By the way, here's the
simple-looking supply
and demand schedules.
These are consistent
with the limit orders.
For example, there's
a maximum price
that a household
is willing to pay.
We go over all the traders.
The max over the max
is the highest demand.
And as price starts
dropping, you'll
pick up a few other traders
who are willing to buy,
but they limited their
order in quantities.
And the price drops some more.
So you get these step functions.
And likewise, for
the suppliers, you
get a step function going up.
As the price gets
higher and higher,
you attract more sellers.
But they have all
submitted limit orders.
So we're looking
for this equilibrium
in this single
dimensional market.
There could be ties.
Supplies equal demand.
We have to have a way of
rationing or allocating the
whatever is short or long here.
In this case, there's
more demand than supply.
So we have to allocate
that across the demanders.
Anyway, these are meant
to be intuitive pictures.
So that's just
describing that picture.
Now, we want to make
sure there are no fails.
So we introduced this lambda.
So lambda is going to
be a penalty function.
And how does it work?
If beta is positive, then
under their strategies
and the strategies
of everyone else,
there's more revenue
than costs, in which
case, beta is positive.
Positive's higher than 0.
This whole term is 0.
There's no penalty.
But conversely, if
beta is negative
because their committed
net expenditure is higher
than their net revenue, then
the minimum of this function
is a negative number.
And it's amplified by lambda.
So lambda is the penalty cost.
It incurs if you overspend.
And of course,
ex-ante, they're going
to choose their strategies
given the strategies
that other people are
adopting in such ways
to maximize this total payoff,
not just the utility of getting
goods if they succeed in doing
that, but also the disutility
if they violate the budget.
So there's a curious
lemma here along the way
that the betas end up being 0.
In other words, in an
active Nash equilibrium,
everyone's on their budget.
Oh, yeah, like the
Walrasian thing, right?
That's what we're looking for.
We're going to try to
support the Walrasian
allocation momentarily.
But one thing-- not the
only thing which is true
of the Walrasian allocation--
is that excess demands
are 0 for each household.
The valuation of what is sold
is equal to the valuation
of what is demanded.
They're in their budget.
Data I is 0.
It turns out, the way
this game is being
defined, beta I must be 0.
Why?
Well, it's deceptively simple.
Let's sum over the betas
of all the households.
That has to be 0.
Why?
Because it's all
in unit of account
if whatever is
spent by me ends up
in the lap of whoever
sold me the goods.
So the unit of account
liquidity is just
passing around the system.
In other words, liquidity always
flows so that it's balanced.
So the sum of the
liquidity deficits
must be 0, because
someone always
ends up holding the liquidity.
And then, you could try
out what would happen
if some beta I were not 0.
Well, if this sum
is 0 and sum beta
I were positive, than if
there's a beta I which is not
0-- say, less than
0-- then there's
some other beta L which
is greater than 0.
Now, that trader
didn't spend all
of his unit of
account valuation.
So that couldn't
be maximal, given
the strategies all the
other players are adopting.
Player L would purchase more.
So the betas have to be 0.
And the final slide here
is, how do we choose lambda?
Or alternatively, given a
competitive equilibrium,
how do we find the
corresponding Nash equilibrium
in this game that achieves it?
But we're given the
prices and allocations
of the competitive equilibrium.
And in a competitive
equilibrium, each trader's
maximizing utility subject to
budget defined by those given
prices, vector p.
That will define the marginal
utility of income, mu,
which coincidentally is exactly
what we called it on Tuesday--
mu I, the marginal utility
of income of trader I, OK?
So what we want is to choose
these penalties high enough
so that the penalty is higher
than the marginal utility
of income.
So mu I is the marginal
utility of income.
We're going to scale
it by something
called alpha in such a way
that we get this inequality.
So you contemplate not
honoring the trade.
That's going to be associated
with this penalty cost lambda.
And that's greater than the
margin utility of income.
You should have
avoided that situation
by not going over your budget.
And so given the alpha, we
can redefine the limit prices
and the limit
quantities in a way
as to achieve a
Walrasian equilibrium.
So we've actually defined
Walrasian equilibrium, Nash
equilibrium, defined a game here
in a market that potentially
has a problem.
Evidently, the penalties
are not high enough.
If we follow this
model, there's a way
to implement penalties to avoid
trade fails so that the Nash
equilibria of that
institutional setup
would correspond with the
Walrasian equilibrium.
OK, so thank you
for coming today.